bombshell's Logan with all of these
pictures of his fiance either basically
nuded with other men no man on this
Earth planet Earth these things being
spoken about their daughter the sister
the mother the Auntie their woman folk
we have something called the protective
jealousy which is in
Islam endorsed by esteemed celebrity Dr
Chris deel MBE from the good morning ITV
show and his celebrity Dr magazine this
exceptional product has been touted as a
remarkable natural alternative for
erectile dysfunction in men and female
sexual arousal disorder in women
formulated with an impeccable blend of
100% natural active ingredients
functioning similarly to pharmaceutical
Alternatives like Viagra for men and
fanin for women our ingenious formula
and extraordinary pills enhance blood
flow relaxing blood vessels and
smoothing muscle
tissue brothers and sisters and dear
friends so if I'm not mistaken I'm not
really aware of what's really going on
Logan Paul appar apparently has a f with
a guy called Dylan the same coward that
khabib and his boy smashed um so as you
can see brothers and sisters that Subhan
Allah when we live in the Western World
in the 21st century and degeneracy prcu
and people having no moral compass and
you can see that they go to any lows for
views money Fame whatever it may be for
that matter if I'm not mistaken I've
heard that they've been cussing each
other's mom and swearing at each other
or all kinds of stuff but it reaches an
all low and to be honest how low can you
get more than this guy Adam 22 I don't
know what his name is who actually
allowed his wife to have intercourse
with another man but he gave some rules
and speculations cuz he is a man and he
had some kind of protective jealousy
which was that and if kids watching
please don't watch this come off
inshallah that he told her that he can
have intercourse with you from all
angles as long as he doesn't you know
forgive me guys you know ejaculate on
your face and you're not allowed to kiss
him on the lips but it's okay he can
penetrate you in different angles
humiliate you it's fine but as as long
as he doesn't ejaculate in your face and
kiss you this is the uh uh the Western
man's moral compass now you can do this
but as long as these guidelines are met
you can't make this stuff up you cannot
make this stuff up if you went to people
in the past in the UK 100 years ago and
said there's going to be a man who's
going to come allow his man to have
inter his man his wife to have
intercourse but he has certain rules
that she shouldn't do they'll be looking
at him thinking well he can do
everything except these it's crazy and
it's Preposterous now the argument here
is that Dylan is making these
accusations about a video that was
leaked which we can watch now next he
tweets um another picture at him her
with this other guy I don't know who
this is he just Bombshells Logan with
all of these pictures of his fiance
either basically nude with other men
there's one there LeBron James oh my
this is wow this is too many
yeah this is just actually crazy wow wow
which is apparently what you just saw
that this is Logan Paul's fiance fiance
to be that she is saying these things
and obviously no man watching this and
even if he's a disbeliever no man on
this Earth planet Earth who is born with
that F which is what that to dislike
these things being spoken about their
daughter their sister their mother their
Auntie their woman folk we have
something called the protective jealousy
which is in Islam our protective
jealousy which the Western men are blam
for you're insecure if you don't let
someone a a a your uh you know your wife
dance with another guy you're insecure
you don't let out with with makeup
you're insecure and there's labels put
into this and Islam has come as an
outright solution why because Islam de
deals with prevention rather than cure
now if this ISO if this story is true or
not let's put Logan Paul story to a side
this is a phenomena that happens to many
many non-muslim men I was a non-muslim
at one point I had many non-muslim
friends and some of them yes they would
hear stuff like oh you know I did this
to your uh your girl or there's pictures
of her here or there's videos here and
these things even traumatized there was
articles showing that a young kid was
bullied at school because his mom does
only fans so the point is what Islam has
a cure for that which is what prevention
don't even go down this route that's why
Allah says in the Quran don't even come
close to it why because at the end of
the day the act of intimacy is something
that has been done to the woman now of
course it's to some people they deal it
and they claim it's a a a um a um social
construct they say oh no it's just a
social construct you know no
this is innately in a man a man does not
like the idea that his wife was with
another man or there's videos and
pictures going it's every single man's
nightmare but Islam also gives a
solution to women who may have fallen
into this because I was a non-muslim at
one point and I made mistakes it might
not be as bad for me as a male a man but
still for a woman is detrimental but
Islam says no problem you committed sins
yes Allah says in the Quran all my
servants who have transgressed against
themselves never ever despair the mercy
of your lord for us as Muslims it is
worse for a person to think that God
will never forgive them that is a
greater sin to think that your sin is
greater than God's mercy so we say to
any woman out there or any man for that
matter but this a issue pertaining to
woman that if this is the case and this
has happened repent your lord there
might be consequences these videos might
come up but ask Allah subhana wa tala to
protect you and my dear non-muslim woman
folk that watching here our sisters in
humanity yes and even some Muslim women
Allah subhana T has honored you yes the
fact that women like to be seen you know
and men like to look it's the modesty
that Allah subhana has given you to
protect you now we are not saying Allah
didn't say in the Quran that men are
animals and they can't control theel
that's why you need to cover up no
that's not true of course there's an
Ayah where Allah subh says that of
course it will protect you to certain
individuals but we would love to live in
a world where this doesn't happen but
Islam deals with a reality the reality
is what there are going to be men out
there who will try it and it also happen
to some women who are dressed up
properly so Allah subhana sent
legislation to woman to behave in a
certain way way and conduct yourself
also to a man to lower your gaze and
behave in a certain conduct have certain
conduct in certain Manner and this is a
solution to the Western world because
there are non-muslim men who literally
are biting their fingers out of Rage
that they are married to a woman who who
they have couple of children with and
they're as videos and pictures popping
up of it just imagine for a second that
there is another man that has a picture
of his wife and he is doing all sorts to
her because like I said before the act
of intimacy is being done to the woman
even if she's on top let's just if we're
going to get to the CL of the matter
yeah she is the one that's being
penetrated and that's the reason why
when a man has an argument with another
man he tends to insult his mother sister
which you can see that's happening in
this fight why why don't they why don't
you see two women boxers who are like
yeah you know you you know what I did to
your man or you know guess what I did to
your brother because the woman will
laugh and be like no actually it was
done to you so we need to understand my
dear brothers and sisters in humanity
Allah subhana wa tala has even a
solution to this how is it possible that
Islam has a solution to all of your
problems we invite you to Islam we
invite you to prevention rather than
having a disease and now looking for a
cure we invite you to Islam our the
Western woman and Muslim men uh
non-muslim men as well come to Islam and
live in an honorable way because
degeneracy promiscuity is destroying the
Western world as we speak and the
non-muslims are even a witness to that
that's why that's why that there is a
rise in people flocking to Islam and
that's why that's why our brother Andrew
T has even shared this fact and he's
mentioned this you know if you are a
Muslim and this can happen to anybody
don't get twisted but if you're a Muslim
man it is less likely less likely
because we haven't dropped that law yet
that you're going to go and then you're
going to have your wife's videos and
pictures and all kinds of stuff God
knows happening God knows what's
happening to her you know and this is
something that is detrimental that can
destroy the family unit inshallah till
next time brothers and sisters
inah